People of Trivantes
sight will return.
Having people be blown away
when they see what season two
looks like.
We are chosen to usher
in a new world.
The level of ambition on this
show was through the roof.
If I do not return,
then I am dead.
Season two picks up about
thirty days after
season one has ended.
And we rejoin Baba Voss
on his way to Trivantes
to rescue his daughter.
Bab's going to face his past
and everything that he ran
from and everything that
kind of made him.
The mighty Baba Voss,
greetings brother.
It's such a dark history,
Baba killed their father
and disappeared.
Edo hated him for many years
because of their shared history,
and when gets wind of Baba Voss
being around again
he's gonna do everything in his
power to destroy his brother.
Advance!
There's danger,
peculiarities pop up.
As the season continues we see
tension build between everyone.
The cracks that were
already starting to show
throughout season one
just start widening.
I think you failed to
realize just how close
to the edge we are.
We're gonna go into this
world that we've
never got to experience
in season one.
It's like he's crawling back
into hell.
This season is the best
season I've ever had.
Most men choose to avoid my
father at any cost.
Now, the general is not
like most men.
And he's been waiting
a very long time to get
his hands on Baba Voss.
♪♪
[screams]
Welcome home Baba.
♪♪